[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody happy Friday how's it
going don't bring in nice yes same cuz
we're playing Gears 5 granted if it
works it is uh it's a versus tech test
we will find out there's the chatter
saying not to bother we're gonna bother
we're gonna bother or bother so much
it's okay let's hop in here yeah we
switch over my screen we've managed to
actually get into a squad so that's yeah
we're in a squad that's good that's a
step tutorial good if you need to
refresh your whole little story stuff
with beard otherwise like have you not
up like use looks like we got five
characters here we got cats Dell JD this
guy's new right I think so maybe yeah
yeah I got old man Marcus warm they
still call them swarm even though
they're like I think so locusts yeah hey
crime how's it going everyone else I
hope you're having a wonderful Friday my
girl my girl Kate I don't even know if
you get to pick your character though I
think he just mess with them yeah who
knows whatever a swarm banner no thanks
oh you get a cool tester banner if you
finish these challenges if you get 50
kills any eliminations bills I win three
vs. matches oh and uh if anyone wants to
know I believe you get access to this if
you're in the tester program or if you
preorder the game
there you go game pass I did pay that
one dollar and get in and get in this
thing I was an idiot and jumped on that
right away not realizing how much more
money it was we're gonna try and load in
here
we're in a squad we're gonna play
together by the way I'm playing on the
Xbox one X yes you're playing on s yes
mine was running at a very smooth I
don't know if it's full 60 but at least
like closer to that yours look more 30
yeah yeah it's definitely not 60 but 1x
looked really good this on the the s
looks pretty good not moving too much
plates from Brazil are nice you don't
even have a person on your main menu
yeah a little weird move due to
inactivity so that's that's what happens
sometimes when you take too long to find
a match you get kicked out of the game
it's definitely witty and definitely
funny banter but they don't call it a
beta but I'm pretty sure we can get away
with saying because because the term
beta has kind of lost all meaning yeah
demo so when when they say tech test
they're like oh no this is a test well
see mr. tech just said in the middle of
match man got booted with your squad due
to inactivity that's how it goes
yeah so we were given priority
matchmaking although Microsoft was like
hey do you give us her gamer tags like
well you're getting in we can boost you
ahead so I might be able to get into a
match
it looks like it's loading thus
interesting the third they're willing to
do that kind of thing
I know I guess they want to make sure
that like streamers I guess see graphics
look really clean they do they do look
really clean I was curious because I was
playing a little bit of for yesterday
yeah like get myself back in the gears
groove and I was like man this game
already looks really good I'm curious
how though
pull up it obviously
I haven't like really compared them side
by side but I'll say that it looks like
it's just got some like cleaner lighting
everything just looks really smooth
there's like very little i canti
aliasing I can see I think it's a really
well put together game yeah Zack says hi
I'm Zack I'm a huge Gears of War fan
you're in the right place I been playing
for yesterday while we were doing it I
kind of I haven't played gears in a
while and I kind of forgot how much I
enjoyed playing it I was like weirdly
just kind of got back into a real quick
I was like okay yeah yeah Crump says
they've had a hard week in the mist a
few streams bull you're here now and I'm
glad that you don't worry a crime and I
hope that whatever's going on gets a bit
better for you understand we love that
you join at any time yeah it says I'm
connecting the server and loading the
map so I might be actually joining you
yeah mine still load and we'll see you
got some weird I don't know what's going
on on your site or it's just like yeah
it's not an ideal loading thing yours
looks more like an actual loading screen
yeah I have this game yeah there's just
a lot of loading that's happening I
guess
hey worst case what we could do is we
can split off into a separate squad yeah
let's try and load them a match whoever
gets in first will just cut to there
just go to that yeah that's right
this turned from a hangout and play
together stream to a see who can
actually get into a game stream favorite
kind of streams gnarly whisker says
let's get it done boys it's a good name
says you're playing a quick play match
and it sued this says that I'm still
loading the map quickest to play matches
right now is happening wait I'm in I
might be in I'm loading in to yeah I got
everything just came together yep there
you are
yeah I'm on the other two oh no I'm on
your team Cooper I was gonna say all
right cool we might have some gears five
here fantastic it may be happening I was
really worried
we're not gonna get kind of same five
minutes to get into a game and a in a
test isn't too bad that's fine I'll take
that Charles says what's going on guys
how's summer going pretty good nice
arcade thank you think so
I'm real worried because I see you all
moving around and I have a thing over my
screen right now that is my bad I think
that wasn't me cuz I think I can see see
people moving her okay I'm in I did it I
said to push a button
let's gears look at all the color yeah
shooter friends friend Gaga oh my god
got a sniper across the way no I made a
mistake I feel like it's quicker to kill
people in this one yeah the time of
killing four is actually pretty long
yeah I see some some stuff going on we
got different hit markers for like head
versus something else so that's exciting
we're getting flanked coming around the
back
and purchase a bull [ __ ] that's sounds
like a good plan I can also do the same
I saw teammate you found well you're
only getting executions oh no I got
chainsawed yes well they have a kill cam
now - yeah you gotta understand that it
is uh this is a tech tests for sure yeah
so there's gonna be some some rough
stuff going on rough stuff although so
far it's pretty pretty smooth yeah
besides taking a while to get in
oh hello incendiary grenades what up
alright I was - uh I'll see you like
gung-ho to use those grenades and then
no that was not the best thing
whoof
God even human shields like get even
through really quick you know people on
the side whew alright alright I'm
killing it right now
alright that was about expect here's
this just there isn't a lot of stuff
that's like it no there really isn't
that's sort of like the the one of the
things I think it's kept alive so long
is that like no game is why captured the
wait years feels even though like a lot
of games to cover that's a thing yeah I
do that I guess I'm really stoked about
how I'm actually like for being so long
I'm doing all right to about a couple
thumb deaths but wow that's gears more
role in the Dark Souls it's true though
oh yes
as soon as someone gets hit they're
rolling off to the side Bob Jones
talking about the color palette yeah
it's looking colorful and a way for
actually have a pretty good amount of
color Wow we're just kind of going
further with it in a way that I'm I like
it yeah same also its color but it's
like I really love how meaty everything
is in gears like getting a head shot
just everything kind of falling apart
it's good
come on commit so you want anywhere to
hide the hi
oh I almost went for the Lancer
is this a PC version of the X version so
what you're watching right now is the
exponent on X this is running on a 1080p
monitor and it looks buttery smooth I'm
curious how the PC version works cuz I
know that yeah also available and then
I'm curious I know that for had cross
play so I think this one does today like
announced until a while ago yeah but I'm
curious if the test does I would assume
that might be a bit much for a test but
I am case
what do you think about this like you
get kills and then it looks like rewards
you with like weapons thing it's
interesting yeah I could get like the
torque bow which I think that might just
be the mode or plan though oh it's it's
a mode thing the things that yeah
cuz it's sort of like a halo 4 thing and
I didn't like it in Halo 4
but I don't know if like that would
bother me the same way in like a Gears
because I'm not as begin to like weapon
placement yeah I think this is like the
the arcade mode or the escalation motor
something that they showed off a little
while ago
I just want to use my Turk Bell and I
shouldn't because I'm terrible with it
oh hello
see that's what my mother's mom man
there we go get a Lancer finally that's
a frightening sound oh god got by it the
two-hour wait time to get in now Oh
didn't do our wait time just go up like
did we did we time it raised well again
we have that priority so oh yeah that
might help us I appreciate that that's a
thing but I kind of wish I'm not not
down with ya but I guess look like it
works for what they wanted which is they
wanted us to be able to play it so that
we can show it off right yeah but I mean
if people we ordered or people are
paying that extra money to be able to
get it and they got to wait two hours
yeah I mean if it's real bad I would
hope they you got Swiss too many bullets
absolutely
I'm all about you hope that they'll
maybe extend it a little bit they kind
of tend to do that
I'd like to win this do not let up
yeah just smoking dudes no I walked
right into the room with three of them
what was I thinking I got one that's all
that happened there's a mere the
graphics worse than before I think
they're better than better you just
played for it might be like a stream
compression thing or something on Cibola
but having just played for the other day
and playing this I think it looks better
also that color palette art direction
brightness looking real good like a real
smooth this game it has a smooth look to
it okay so if I were to do this yeah how
do you how do you get the Lancer I don't
know I've just been finding it off in
people okay cuz I can only by a bull
talk in a torque Bo are you seeing
people are finding it on the maps I
still think there are map weapons almost
know how I feel about finding a Lancer
oh shoot I said boom shot
to prevent player try eroding on a lot
more always being cover VOC around on
the open too much hey we're just trying
to get back into that that gears flow
it's been a very long time but those are
also very good tips let me do it I'll
take it I died right after taking all
right but think we lost though just
barely I know but I got that kill at the
end yeah yeah I like this kind of a
highlight thing though where it shows
whoever whoever did the best that's cool
good warm up a good first match 17 and
10 isn't bad for my first game in Gears
five some it could be better obviously
we're going to just let it go let it go
not touch it hopefully we get to keep
going
was it the Queen I don't know there's
there is a woman on the boxart that's
like a locust queen kind of looking sick
I'm gonna vote anyway because I'm still
here no I can vote
it just wouldn't show me my progress and
Ambu me out Oh everything is arcade
deathmatch training grounds training
grounds for training grounds mmm that's
a tough call I'm going what if I
switched it to the other training
grounds where would we be what would we
do to win district was pretty good
yeah I like that map that's fun so
training grounds is cool this is the the
map that you do the Oh tutorial on if
you see the background it's built on the
ruins of the house of sovereign which is
that location from here's one yeah where
you find Coltrane and Baird want to see
more district we'll probably end up
switching back and forth as we play I'm
guessing that's how how lobby's will
probably shape up unless people are just
like the real thing I mean I don't know
how many maps there are I think it's
just - oh really okay I'm just going off
with the voting that we have don't worry
you'll see plenty of district games suck
loading on districts give give it some
time we had to wait a bit I was actually
stuck watching everyone run around
there's a five hour wait now holy geez
I'm so sorry guys that's rough so we're
gonna just hope that we don't get kicked
out because yeah we're just gonna do our
best to stick with this and hope that we
but man that first match was fun I don't
know play gears one point gears we're
playing gears debisch blinkers we should
probably play poison for ya Matt Matt
Benelli has been playing through all the
gears games yeah just completely
unprovoked out of nowhere and we were
like dude horde mode yeah let's go let's
do the horde mode force horde mode was
good I love I love three so much threes
definitely want to played the most
threes the bass so much for no interest
in Gears five it wasn't on my
immediately I wasn't kind of like oh
yeah I can't wait for Gears until I've
got my hands on it and I'm like oh yeah
gears a good time weird back and forth
of Gears five where I liked four but at
the end of the day it didn't get me like
super jazzed about more gears kind of
like the more I thought about it yeah
and then I saw that trailer last year
four five hmm man that story is tough
and they're like hey like Kate's down
the main character and they were showing
it I was like that really looks great
I'm really excited for this game I'm
like super interested whoo excuse me
you know what trailer didn't get me was
that weird Billy Eilish yeah I was so
III 20:18 really excited for Gears v III
2019 wasn't really that interested in
what they showed I didn't care for that
Billy Irish trailer I the I haven't
obviously played escape but what showed
with super cool it's okay for me so it's
kind of like you look like you're in
here press B yeah see yeah that's good
to know thank you I figured that out
last time cuz I was like I can't see
here and wait I mean it's validating the
match so that's fine
but at least it's something to look at
oh heck yeah
Lazarus wants to know if we do a gear
series like we did with Mortal Kombat I
kind of like that like quick hit like
going back and seeing things like I do I
would love to do that with the
multiplayer like get everyone together
in place in like gears do some private
gears matches especially because if you
have game paths you have access to every
Gears game they're all fans
compatibility and I know that they made
both two and three got that that 4k made
it in go change character no well let me
change character well I mean I don't
need to change him no it totally well
let me change character I don't want to
worry about that but what if I were
Marcus yeah it's like houseless
sovereigns up there we're just cool
that's a nice little touch for you uh
your fans out there yeah your heads
I'm looking the wrong way got one down
oh shoot he's got friends
tiny bit
Benedick you feel old on apologies that
was just the worst aiming I my entire
life
well you're also trying to coordinate
the stream to
oh my god holy crap what is up everybody
it's the entire team yeah well I got one
of them
I didn't realize three people walked up
behind me while I was trying to I
thought I saw that happen to you
good girl I know and then they all came
for me woohoo they're good at teaming up
like in it they're sticking in a group
and we need to do that god I love the
bull talk so much it's got a real like
beefy mechanical sound now to you says
40 hours holy cow - the 17 Yates get
some rest get some dinner take a shower
make a sandwich
I was Kate complimenting Kate on a
really good headshot guys really good at
running away hell yeah ah dang it
those miracles I ruined it I was gonna
get him okay and try to do a full
Constitution oh shoot I should have let
you do it I'm like I'm the cop I've
ruined it there I got two down for us
you can you do the thing three down over
here and a group let's call it a little
bit
whoa hello that's right I'll just knock
down all these people all right got a
lance there yeah how do you get a Lancer
I've only ever been picking it up off
dead bodies
oh this is just out math yeah this is a
heck of a thing
hey everyone what's up
your dad
your dad
dad it was a good kick thank you
it's not homeboy there you go you did it
yeah
what is with these people they're just
running right at us no I don't know oh
we're playing against yeah there's a lot
of bugs that explains I'm like do these
players are lifeguards just running in
it's because we're playing against bots
that explains everything
not hey cuz it's not even like I'm not
even playing that good like I was like
you know what sucks is the fact that
there are people waiting in 17-hour
queues right now who's right now and
we're playing we're playing it's got
lots oh that explains everything
we are we playing against any real
people we have to be there has to be one
that's good well if it loads they might
not you do it from the oh there it is
yeah check I can't even we might be
playing entirely because the AI
there's one off the side nope no I think
they're all AI dude that person might be
a real person oh that one is yes there's
like one real dude on their team come on
try me
press the map on don't hold it thank you
yes there's one real person on their
team and you and me are the only real
people on our team
yikes dang that blows get the real
people in yeah where's the real people
man we got a bunch of lovely people in
our chat who are waiting 17 hours we've
got all this space this is messed up I
agree
one day I'll get a torque Pro kill and
it'll be great chance Raquel I'm playing
against bots cos very few people play
xbox I can't imagine that's the case I
got Adam I made out wrong but I would
just see more people are playing on the
Xbox yeah
at least we're showing the game off yeah
that I can definitely agree with
I'll be honest don't even mind that it's
against computer guys yeah sex place
where AI is just like stealing all my
kills it is weird to have to hold up the
chainsaw with our RB RB yeah that's a
change so any sort of like hey you still
melee but it's now like a knife attack
instead and then it's like if you want
to do chainsaw you have to hold down
right bumper which is twenty five and
six man I sure worked all those BOTS
there's the one guy in there sitting
specs so many people to take advantage
of gamer path ultimate maybe there's
gotta be some sort of weird math to it
because if we have a match where there's
only three human players out of okay
there's like two sides of people
probably at like the coalition right now
there's like the PR side who's like this
is a disaster everyone's mad at us
please fix it then there's the engineers
who are like no this is exactly what we
wanted we wanted them to break it
immediately so that we can troubleshoot
it because that's the whole point of the
test right it's like you got to imagine
there's there's some people there who
are like you need to there's no reason
to be like that we're with you on it
that's really stupid but yeah
you know it looks pretty slow not as
compared to uncharted yeah I mean I'm
sure yours are not the same they're
definitely not the same game at all yeah
they change how to use the weapons so
now you've got like a standard melee
with like a knife on B and to do a shoot
I just pressed B and to do your chainsaw
you have to press right bumper it's fine
it's just weird cuz you're not used to
it yeah I hate the fact that I pressed B
though well I was talking about the
buttons because now I'm not in the match
I have to try to reconnect this is the
first of a few tech tests I hope so
alright I'm back at it I'm joining on
you again I'm in here thanks for the
great gate we're trying our best for you
as long as you're having a good time our
best 23 our Q something something
something isn't right it's only how
people think it for money for this game
not to work that's what we're saying I
agree but also I don't know I'm very
understanding it's a tech test but I
don't know if if you advertise it as a
thing then that's that's a problem sure
if we want to get into the logistics of
using money to incentivize technical
tests that may not work yeah
yes there is a hundred percent an
argument to be had I think things like
technical test should just be free yeah
I think they should just be free because
then it sets that expectations of yo
this is a technical test yeah right
making it a pre-order bonus kind of
gives with a different expectation so a
hundred percent understand why I feel
frustrated I don't think Dustin's gotten
into a game yet or maybe his score
hasn't updated it would invite him to
our thing we should probably just get
him in here could use more players
other than tech test next weekend maybe
things will be more ironed out by then
there you go I'm back in I've done it we
got no one else though
it's okay it's got to validate the match
and then just got to bring in the bots
it's just gonna be us against BOTS
see
it is you always got to bring it back
that it is a like a beta type thing
yeah what what's what's crime saying I
just grieve this is a guarantee that if
this happens on the release the problem
that's true yeah like if this if this
was the case like launch day then it's
like I don't think it'll happen launch
day I don't know I mean I'm really
curious what it is that's happening here
because clearly people aren't getting in
that should be getting in because we're
not getting matched with other people
but it's like yeah like presumably the
whole reason you have a tech test like
this this is that on launch day this
doesn't happen right back to here's for
totally casual I hope that you guys who
did get it get in here as far as a fun
time
I wouldn't call a tech test low maybe
beta I mean they literally call it
attacked yeah they I think they avoided
using the exact word yeah baby like
they're their exact wording is tech test
maybe your tour objectives are way
different than mine what is this I think
we're against AI again I think you are
to 100% yeah that's fine
at this point we're just here to show it
off it's playing the game whoa hello
okay cool flip that happens not you I
don't want you to get me Joe no got me
that's no good
hello
yeah
Morty flipping bull talk town USA
population me Oh huh hello howdy just
hanging out with my partner here I
ruined it there you go that one's for
you you trying to do some execution
kills I'm getting caught up in the in
the business there's one of these dang
it that's weird
I'm like holding B and then it like
there you go god yeah you know I might
be pressing it too soon there you go
yeah oh my god
grenade launcher Lancer okay thank you
yes no I haven't seen the grain launcher
but I imagine there's not all the
weapons
we're playing on exercise I'm playing on
X so the footage you're watching this X
Ben's playing on mess and what it's it's
definitely like a more 30 per Bowl you'd
say so I think it might be 30 in story
but while I'm playing now at 60 oh okay
so there might be something like
graphical exception yes I can tell
mine's like I think it might be super
sampling a little bit so it looks a
little bit nicer
there we go gum I'll answer back
yeah yeah I need a chainsaw someone it's
not gear so cheese letting me do it
come here you're right there you're
right on the edge yeah
this on pc it is on PC we're not playing
it on PC but data or Monday that's very
technical test is available on oh I'm
sorry that was my bad it's all good I
did the things that I said then the
default pistols not bad if you get like
the recoil right you can still put a
grenade on someone's head dangit Dell
how much this game Pass so ultimately
there's ultimate game passed which is
like but PC it's everything that's for
PC you get game pass for Xbox and you
also it comes with gold right yeah idea
that's 15 a month but you get the first
month for like a dollar so if you're
just like hey I kind of want to check it
out you can check it out for like a
dollar still trying to get in and change
my character works
oh and then regular yeah
Marcus is saying in the chat saying
regular is finales all new games
available yes as far as I'm aware which
every like first party Microsoft game
has been available on game pass doesn't
mean every new game ever is available
but just uh definitely all Microsoft
games and then I think there maybe are a
couple third-party games they do deals
right I think if you're someone who's
like just invested in the Xbox ecosystem
like game passes seems like a really
good deal woof is this live right now
this is definitely live right now
beowulf enstein also a fantastic name oh
hey I think another person joined we got
people oh my god there are people in
this we are playing against this is
great and I died because I was
distracted BF for example like if you
get game path side you get access to
every Gears of War game
including four which is like a really
good deal okay
yes what let me yep yep don't kill me
alright I mean like yeah you should do
that but also
okay that's definitely a player that I'm
fighting against right now I know they
have I think they have it like two
fighters on I think we got real people
finally you tell Marcus
I was gonna pick that person up but then
they've let themselves on fire whoo oh
man
everyone's on fire everyone dies
come back here
BAM got him yeah oh I got MVP that time
maybe like the one they let the gate
down and people are finally coming in do
that looking out how valiant I am what
was my 24 eliminations successful crew
except for one and they had at least two
people that's way better than I think
we've gone before it's getting there
we're about halfway through this dream
by the way I'm doing 42 minutes I know I
real quick yeah what if we just played
Gears the whole what if Comic Con got
put on hold and we can just play Gears
the whole time
yeah I'm sure I could convince time so I
put put Comic Con on hold it's all good
how do you get into the test
you've got to either have game pass
ultimate or you've got to have
pre-ordered the game ordered
wonder if they know you're live
streaming Oh as far as this getting into
a match well so we were saying before to
lift the veil a little bit Microsoft
Italy asked for our gamer tags so that
we could get like priority access to the
like the queue line yeah which I guess
is a thing they probably sent out to
like streamers and stuff so that they
can guarantee the streamers are playing
so that's probably how we're getting
access quicker than everyone else um and
I just I wish it would just take me in
to the game I just want to keep going
yep
I don't want to exit match because then
that'll like boot us out and I'm like
don't do that I already did that once do
we want to try so we're doing arcade
quick play do we want us to try I think
this is the only thing with Jenna no no
there was um there was there was like a
rank thing really
there was a rank thing you won't try to
rank thing oh I don't know if we should
just stick with where we're at to be
safe come on try it though all right all
right yeah yeah I'm gonna bring my squad
with me take me with you
not hitting stop and then start on that
anyone know the file size it's like 10
gigs this thing is so hot
all right started it up again okay
so I'm gonna give a give a shake here at
the COS yeah see quick play I'm so my
thing I don't know if we try right you
can only do five matches of each here
here don't don't hit it yet till I'm
back in the main just to be safe let's
do escalation I guess so since you're my
squad I mean I'm still saluting in oh
yeah won't even let you I've been
removed from the game because that's not
oh okay
oh they make a move for my squad okay
now it's claiming your
still in a faint even though you well I
think it's still catching up because
everything is very slow i I'm not in
your squad anymore even no oh you're not
yeah it says you're still in my squad
not yet allies doesn't even mean damn
now I'm gonna get you back in my squad
Joe my squad still says I'm waiting for
hosts I think it's confused else is I on
your screen says I'm in quick play which
is definitely not true you know if
that's case I'm gonna I'm gonna hit my
leave squad button yeah there it is
there's the Nasher that's there we go
come on let me join oh shoot
I think it's cuz you you you cute in oh
okay Oh something five matches to give
you a wink oh I was gonna say like five
matches that doesn't make any sense to
me
alright alright I'm joining again I jump
a saying welcome to loading screen I'm
in video game I squat yes oh [ __ ] I
actually get to change my character I
like backed out movie Marcus and now I'm
just stuck at this menu whoops I have a
loadout screen happening dang show swarm
character I should have backed out I
messed up there's my swarm character
that guy is pretty gross looking there I
am let's go with him okay I mean cool
we've done it so you gonna be Marcus
yeah I'll be Dell
and yeah we're doing escalation cream
match what's my swarm boy look like so
escalation I think is the mode where
you've got to be really like like you
like draft weapons sort of okay see
what's so good about this so it's Q's
multiplayer oh yeah like dance Gears of
War just Gears of War
if you don't like gears then there's
nothing I can do to like kind of
convince you it's just a fun violent
game silly silly sometimes over the top
sometimes can be kind of serious and sad
too
it's multiplayer like everyone's got
weight to them like a half that that's
pretty unique we've made it we did it
real players - oh do we go to district
or training grounds so I wonder if if
ranked you'll never get BOTS you know
what I mean I think maybe we can't you
can't get ranked against bots it's
available on PC but we're playing on the
Xbox yes indeed let's stay here and spin
Marcus around all lunch yeah that uh
that frame rates like look at that
versus mine yeah that is the people in
the stream can see yeah
if only he got sick and threw up just
like snake does in Metal Gear Solid 3 I
mean I'm not gonna say it's I'm saying
that gears gameplay if you're not into
gears as a whole it this is still like
gears but it's definitely making a lot
of big improvements I wouldn't call it
gears 4.5 especially only off of playing
at technical tests there's a campaign
for the new gears yeah there is there's
a they always have a good good old
campaign yeah I don't think gears can
survive just as a multiplayer thing yeah
I'm more in it for the story and the
horde mode yeah I think I think it needs
that like whole package of like campaign
horde you know the multiplayer is a good
time I got that new thing I'll escape
I'm kind of curious about it is
definitely one of the best series for a
co-op campaign yes 200% absolutely
is it is a weird thing to kind of just
be like yeah I really like the story and
Gears of War is like anyone who doesn't
know anything about Gears kind of looks
at it in his life yeah more real now
because oh shoot
Savage dreams and savage smoker are here
we're fighting against the clan
leet-speak I'm ready I'm feeling it okay
grab these points and head towards a we
got people coming in looks like - yeah
I'm just waiting for us to get flanked
by someone else like a try there's not
much cover on the side that I'm on I can
go around the other way
Jeremy I go around the long way I'm not
gonna go around the long way there's
someone else trying to do the same thing
over here in the market oh he's got a
shotgun out
it must be gears time what's not rooted
all the to ask who sue ain't no thing I
respawn in I see this is where like the
real people play yeah this there are
people who are moving like professional
Gears of War players yeah get him yeah
oh yeah this guy's a gears player I was
afraid to use the respawn because I'm
like there's definitely someone who
could use that over me oh oh maybe we
have like a pool of lives i demolition
had taken that respawn cuz i mean it we
died that's all good it's just technical
tests oh yeah and we have to pick the we
have to weapon draft
oh yeah this is their other big mode
that they did like a whole trailer for
this person's not taking anything to
read though was it I want to say I
remember weapons drafting being a thing
in three I could be crazy one of the
funniest guys on GameSpot to put three
sighs man you guys are too nice to us
but I'm very glad also I wasn't the one
who Platinum Secura
but I appreciate it anyway yeah you look
like the person who's a singer plan
Decker Jake also a very good yeah person
too though I appreciate the compliment
nonetheless
Dell's got a point rev up the Lancers
well good you can still rev it never
mind this is still still good gears
still doing it I'm just gonna swoop wide
and see if I can catch any of them maybe
I can take a and they won't even notice
me
hmm I've done it
I haven't done it I've lied I can't
compete ruff you're still awesome thank
you but I hate it's worth mentioning
that if you guys are enjoying what
you're seeing and you enjoy us should
definitely follow the channel give us a
subscribe we stream every weekday at 11
a.m. Pacific John Luke and I
specifically on Fridays usually in an
attempt to play a game with you guys in
the community though today we've decided
to play the gears 5 beta because it's a
pretty big deal look at this person oh
yeah they're there they're playing Gears
man Jacob Rooney's we shouldn't score
any more points as we've got 69 that's
about my cruise experience goes as I
miss every shotgun blast and then I get
killed you can't play terrible
also I'm just gonna steal all the
respawns because people are here just to
watch play watch me play it badly oh ha
it's I'm not prepared for the the
shotgun stuff like I should be I know
you know that's that's fair slaps yeah
definitely should probably play more
gears but it's been a while since gears
4 came out and they're a bunch of other
games I've got to play how you doing on
your screen just about the same really
be honest do you want people to switch
over to yours oh god you know if you're
playing better I'm happy to accommodate
that I mean I'm taking points but I'm
just not getting anymore
I'm not getting any kills I'm not
getting any murders I'm doing real bad
on the murder front
elated says here's a question if you had
to choose between cutting off your legs
and playing gears or judgment which leg
would you cut off first that's a good
question I'll take one of our many
copies for some reason in our office we
have like just no one wants to take
those I didn't like judgment like at all
yes as I mentioned before I'm at
Spinelli's been playing through all the
gears games and he played through all of
them including four and then he's like
I'll go play judgment now and then he's
like I don't want to keep playing this
but uh yeah maybe I'm not ready for
ranks yeah I was during that weird
period of time where they made everyone
just kept making prequels because
everyone was just waiting for the next
console generation to start and they
were all pretty flashback whatever
except for Halo Reach that was maybe the
only really good one yeah yeah there's
anything new about this game besides
executions and game types to it I've
only been able to play this technical
test I haven't really looked much up
about it to be honest but uh it feels
good to play still I don't know what
exactly else they've done to change a
lot of stuff time to get messy
I may not be able to do any good
murder kills but I can take a mean
circle actually like judgment that's I
mean hey hey judgment I've no desire try
it again play twice geppu hoy messed up
this looks like a 360 game you might
have to go back and play a 360 game but
there's some like like Symphony sound
set oh hey the domination has shot a man
I barely got to do anything
I took a circle I can figure oh good
that the the actually keep track of the
caps and breaks too so I can at least
like yo my numbers weren't hot but these
numbers were just gotta have a two-hour
wait
some people were saying earlier that
there's like a 24-hour wait I'm glad
that it seems to be getting a little bit
better but got to hours are still alive
a lot
i matcha still full about this one is
not because we're doing a ranked match
we've traded playing with a bunch of
real people who were serious before we
arcade and now we're on ranked and I
think with ranked there are no BOTS like
it'll it'll only do real players well
arcade it'll kind of have BOTS to sort
of fill in matches and then it'll slowly
replace them with real people so we're
also doing a lot I kind of like arcade
more well yeah I mean ranks a little
more like we're here to play gears now
everyone just roll around like crazy
with a sure people were doing the wall
bounce stuff and that's when I know I'm
in a place where I shouldn't be
nice
that one I'm about to get got
I didn't get got I did the getting good
job
uh uh
oh [ __ ] I nice me at least to get a
watch something cool happen so there is
a way you can counter them when someone
goes back to you I got another one but
you got like time the B button it's
happening to the matrix this guy's like
movement is he on PC no it look at that
though that that's just how good people
are guess he's got the wall bounce but
like I'm looking at it's like he's like
dude I don't you know what I mean this
is like can you even move I know my
shotgun out apparently a lot of people
are having long queues to get in which
seem to be getting better based off what
people have been saying but they're
still not great don't forget I'm worth
it so that's how you're supposed to play
yeah well but oh definitely wall
bouncing I was just more looking at like
though the speed of that game and I'm
like either it's just like they gotta be
on like top ten sensitivity for sure I'm
probably never gonna wall bounce some
gears cuz I'm not I'm not that I don't
know if I'm that serious about playing
years I'm a very casual Gears fan
definitely not hardcore like Oh like I
said story mode and horde mode
I like multiplayer sometimes with my
friends I like that arcade mode a lot
the arcade mode was fun I mean that's
kind of more we're like I'll spend my
time in multiplayer is like more casual
stuff like I'll never get into like a
wings
oh I'm coming to help capture got you
all right so we've got see it's moving
on a god whoa
I should try to make a move to pick up a
retro Lancer to be honest
see that's the other problem I have with
this since this is a long game mode yeah
its first two seven and we're three and
one
well we could do this one and then after
that we could go back to arcades and it
yeah we it was good to try this mode
though
we have a problem starting up the game
we didn't have too much of a problem we
we had some issues like getting into a
party and just general getting into a
game and management has been there kind
of taken forever but we've also just
been kind of like trying to ride it out
whenever we get it to work I am right
behind you listen you should go for it
gonna go for it and just get right in
front of that shotgun shot
oh all right gonna forget one but not
the other guy
oh called it got him nice die
never mind everything is worth it that
was great all the seven rounds all that
everything worth just hearing Marcus
yell that do it again let's do it again
good done that better there are multiple
dudes over where you're at
yeah it's kind of their their area I
think mr. channel about just like cyborg
man says it's about video games baby
yeah we're gonna be where we're gonna
win the damn
Oh No Prezi is killing it we're gonna
win in a hundred seconds we have no more
responds but we're gonna win everybody
oh yeah the other thing just a heads up
if you take too long in the menu you're
gonna get kicked for inactivity if you
take too long while your matchmaking you
might get kicked for inactivity it's
like maybe try to like move your stuff
around in the menu or something while
you're you're doing things because that
actually happened twice while we were on
the stream to reconnect your input
device see there you go it's already
happening you got oh what yeah hello if
you controller might be low on batteries
possibly no huh
nights nah man
oh shoot that's a it's a good shout out
apparently gears 4 is on sale for ten
dollars right now in the Windows Store
if you like nonsense and chainsaws
elated it's got the best way to sell it
if you're like interested in five that's
like a good way to like pick up on it
also you have a game pass you just get
it for free that's true
I'm still thinking about when Marcus got
that chainsaw also this might go all the
way until the end of the stream or a
little bit sorry that's how B yeah yeah
carefully choosing here we're gonna be
dropping it looks like a smoke grenade
possibly a flashbang to the right side
of our spawn mm not quite bold move
cotton see if it pays off other even new
weapons the other a few new weapons woof
so I'm just gonna sit here and try not
to die Marcus no I'd like to get you but
uh it's okay you were gonna get guy
if you trick your response this guy's
already respawn three times
yikes
bad at this Jesus like that was like a
given
come back fighting against boss another
demon claws uh yeah
let's hello doesn't matter the leg I
went to more we could actually get some
more arcade games and get off so I can
get on
fortunately doesn't work that way
opening Pluto I wish that I could give
my spot up to someone though when we do
have to leave or something also rude the
reflex is a little slow it is my
reflexes are not following day stop
talking no dude but I gotta talk all
right why why else would we be doing
this you know Jesus
oh if I waited like a split second
longer I would have been able to do it
no that is a good alternative if you
don't like the talking you cuz you don't
have to be here though
I hope that you wouldn't want to leave
though not me reflux guy I know that
some of the chat I guess could just mute
the video but then you still got a look
at me
forgot about hail and forza i'm so
stoked for everyone to be playing halo
in 2019 when it comes out on pc i just
want more halo to happen I'm excited for
that as well
I'm stuck at 45 minutes for an hour now
god that's I still gotta wonder what it
is I wonder if the other modes are
starting to actually fill up with people
or not cuz I hope so yeah well don't
worry well definitely lose this round
and then we can maybe do one more arcade
that's what I'm here for
we hear anything about the new Halo game
nope nothing new that but that III
trailer though looking real good
alright I'm gonna grab f cuz I'm already
trying to pay respects for the fact that
I'm about to die
Yanni's
Thanks Oh took out his legs are you ad
over by D see that long shot there we go
me and other Marcus we're doing this
we're doing it for a bit G so Pete's
markets guys hello
what was that award that I got
Piketty crunch you did it Congrats my
dude top top-tier rolling don't middle
middle the squad
I don't feel too bad about that I
definitely don't feel great about that
performance hey listen guys yeah my
squad with me
Skyler's ranked match nonsense oh it's
actually taking me with you this time I
think as this is going on today it's
gonna pick up and get better less wait
times every server seemed to be catching
up because before it took literally five
minutes for me to get to the screen
after you try to drag us out and I'm
already back in the menu yeah okay
arcade because that'll be easier
Chris I'll be polite yeah it's no reason
to be like that
hanging out and playing video games my
dude is Friday get excited we have a
weekend coming up got in quick enough
yeah I'm serious when I think I said I
think it's getting better I think
everything's kind of coming together yes
we got people here yeah we're doing it
I've gotten 80 eliminations so I finally
finished that okay hopefully these
people are not as are 80 eliminations in
in less than an hour and a half
a lot of those robots hey you know
eliminations are illuminations it's true
that's where I am okay
still validating the match its horde
60fps uh Madden showing horde off yet we
got some sweet chats oh just get that
real quick I'm gonna listen to it on my
end let me see what happens
not a lot of lobbies that you actually
talk across teams before the match kicks
off that's exciting
bring back some of those trash-talking
halo two days
Nimue and the chat is saying that all
modes are supposed to be 60 FPS 4k at
least that's what they say I'm assuming
that mean he's on 1x
on 1x cool still Odin in ah cool
you have been removed from the game you
have been kicked from a little answer
that's good I'm trying to join you again
when one day you got some smoke happenin
one come on
that was the father that makes sense
random weapon so sounds like there are
other modifiers head yeah just like a
random like we got a random grenade I
like the idea of just have stick I like
throw his feet up real good
she playing 23 minute cue we got in a
bit earlier and we got like a like a
weird Microsoft priority thing
unfortunately though it seems to not be
working because I can't join it all
these people are more my speed for sure
oh go play
Toros are legit try enjoin right brains
like red baby enemy
Chucky's moon says that they'd body
everyone there I invite you to come in
and hang out when the the game launches
and I probably be able to do some some
verses man yeah come back in November
and body the [ __ ] out of us
heck yeah because if you don't know what
John Luke and I do usually it's trying
to play with with people in the chat but
every Friday is community Friday it's
this week we've got year's multiplayer
happening and I can't even join John
Luke right now I'm mentally keeping it
in my head I'm gonna be like year's five
launch day or not launch date launch
whenever we are able to do our community
Friday stream I'm gonna look forward to
seeing chunky moon come in and show off
their gear skills yeah sweet we we
invite anyone good bad whatever we're
just want to have a good time it's all
good
[Applause]
how's bad maybe that's why I like arcade
you don't really get shotguns I didn't
even think about that until you
literally said that give me a random one
you got the claw yeah it's like an
assault rifle that's got like okay but I
think the the bottom of it also changes
your melee no anything on it's got real
long reload
yikes kind of kind of mulches people a
little bit still can't join but that's
fine
soon a few mates yeah I keep being like
red enemies yeah we haven't played as
the locusts or not those the swarm
literally the entire time we've been
playing I think she's Marcus oh my god
video game calmed down to video games
never gonna calm down been one minute
for like an hour
god geez Marcus just gave birth what
what what did he say Oh No so he called
fire and then he just he was dead and he
was just screaming for like 30 seconds
it was real yikes oh hey I got kicked
for an activity and then the game
updated and it's telling me that you're
a new ally for me and not just a random
person thanks so much
we're buddies now I still can't join you
though oh we got so that's interesting
the more you play with certain people
you level up your friendship level with
them and you get next P bonus yeah you
get your social links up with your
actual friends and then you get bonus xp
for doing it so right now
for playing with you I get 2% extra X
because we're the first level
let's get that friendship with y'all the
9000 do give that friendship over 9000
that's that's the me me response I'm
here for it
will get that that friendship bond over
make it happen
so sarin a delish silly one one day
hollows too high here degeneracy hey I
keep doing it
keep shooting don't let your memes be
dreams you got a you got a show I've
been duded I haven't been able to play
this whole last match oh come on for
that that's enough time for a full match
so did we want to just call here uh I'm
gonna do whatever it is pretty close we
could try one more but also it's Comic
Con so we probably shouldn't
let's call so thank you for joining us
everybody yeah hopefully you got some
entertainment some fun out of that the
that rank stuff was cool that was rough
because well I've never been like a high
level gears player at all which doesn't
surprise me that that's where all the
people went because it's ranked but uh
I'm enjoying this tech test even with
the obvious bugs and stuff that are
coming along with it being a tech test
yeah yeah hopefully you guys who have
all been trying to get in are able to
get in you're able to enjoy it hopefully
they'll kind of get all this ironed out
and maybe later tonight or hopefully
tomorrow for the weekend yeah sounds
like they might have a couple tests
throughout before the game comes out so
hopefully you'll get plenty of chances
to try the game outs and yeah that is
that is it for us that's it for this
Friday yeah we'll be back next week with
something so there will be some be
something mark our words
on this channel at 11 a.m. Pacific every
weekday you will definitely find some
sort of video game something be it with
us or with anyone else but it's sure to
be a good time thanks everybody
Charles don't worry about it we
appreciate you yeah check it out being
in here in the stream Thanks
all right guys muy bye I'm gonna find
the button to turn the stream off no I
got it
yeah you got that yep yeah do it whoo
yeah
[Music]
[Music]